[Musique]
souvenez vous le c septembre dernier
l'ex star du loft loana posté une vidéo
pour le moins inquiétantes sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'ai fêté mes chiens quelques jours plus
tard lohan a dévoilé des photos de son
corps recouvert d'hématomes apparemment
causée par son ex petit ami fred cauvin
ce dernier était venu répondre à ces
accusations le 22 septembre sur notre
plateau en nous expliquant que loana
était dans un état de détresse totale
havas au suicide avec toutes les drogues
qu'elle consomme aujourd'hui mais si
l'homme nié être l'auteur de ces
violences la mère de loana quand elle
avait confirmé les faits et même tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé après que loana est
publié une photo d'elle entièrement nul
j'ai vu ma fille couverte de bleus au
mois d'août
c'est fred qu'il a tapé à la des bleus à
des endroits où ce n'est même pas
possible que ce soit elle qui les effets
mais aujourd'hui mardi 6 octobre nouveau
coup de tonnerre dans cette affaire
loana aurait ted est transporté
d'urgence à l'hôpital bichat dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris
alors que s'est-il vraiment passé
alors gilles vous avez toutes les
informations à ce sujet qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à 16h15 loana est sorti
de son domicile dans le 8e
arrondissement de paris elle est sortie
en courant
elle avait l'air hébété elle a commencé
à se déshabiller elle a traversé une
ruelle avec deux amis qui étaient en
face dans un quatrième chien voilà elle
voulait attraper son chien l'a traversé
en courant la failli se faire écraser
les deux amis ont réagi à ce moment là
ils ont vu l'état de loana bon on savait
depuis particulièrement les dernières 48
heures que ça n'allait pas du tout loana
avec kelly on avait des informations
comme quoi elle était en perte de
lucidité dans un état second souvent ses
amis ont paniqué ils ont dit on peux pas
la laisser comme ça les policiers et les
pompiers sont intervenus assez
rapidement pendant ce temps là ses amis
sont montés chez elle parce qu'elle
avait tout laissé ouvert donc on pouvait
tout lui volumes et les policiers et les
pompiers
en accord avec les amis même si loana
était un peu réticente au début on vu
que la seule solution était de
l'hospitaliser en urgence à bichat
effectivement pour qu'au moins 2 soit
prise en charge son agent était là voilà
l'état cela ça va pas très bien mais on
espère qu'avec la prise en charge à la
s'améliorer on est tout coeur avec elle
parce que la pl passe qu'elle traverse
l'aï vraiment très délicate